The end of last class,
I suggested that from here on out,
I'm going to be assuming
that there is no soul.
I'm going to be discussing the class
discussing the issues that we turned to
hereafter from the perspective of the
physicalist person who says that a person
is basically just a fancy body,
a body that can do certain special tricks,
a body that can function in certain ways
that we associate with being a person,
a body that can pee function as we put it.
Yeah,
no,
I've given you my reasons for believing.
There are no souls basically that the
various arguments that might be offered
for believing in souls,
uh,
don't seem very compelling
upon examination.
So there's no good reason
to posit this extra entity.
Okay.
For the most part that I'm going to be
putting aside soul talk periodically.
I'll come back and talk about how a
some issue that we are considering might
look from the perspective of somebody
who does believe in souls. But as I say,
for the most part, I'm going to
be assuming there are no souls,
but those of you who still do
believe in the existence of souls,
I suppose you could take a great deal
of the discussion that follows as some
form of large conditional or subjunctive.
You know,
if there were no souls,
then here's what we'd have to say.
So although I'll be largely talking from
the perspective of the physical list,
if you know, if you haven't become
convinced of the truth of physicalism,
so be it.
Well,
at least explore what will we say about
death if we've decided that people are
basically just bodies.
Now,
you'll recall that at the
start of this semester,
I said in thinking about the question,
could I survive my deck?
There were two basic things
we had to get clear on. First,
we had to get clear on what am I,
what are my parts?
And that's why we've spent the last
several weeks worrying about the question,
am I just a body and my body? Am I a
body and an immaterial soul as well?
Or perhaps strictly speaking,
just the soul.
Having looked at that question,
we're now going to turn to
the second basic question.
What would it be to survive?
What would it be for a thing
like that to continue to exist?
Now,
of course we're going to ask
most particularly particularly
what would it be for
a thing like that to survive the death
of the body couldn't even make sense for
a person to survive the death of his body.
Okay?
You might think the answer to that
is no if we are physical lists,
but in fact it's not so clear.
The answer to that is no,
but in order to address
that particular question,
what does it for me to
survive the death of my body?
Is that even a possibility or not?
We first have to get clear
about the more general question.
What does it for me to survive,
period.
Take them more familiar humdrum case.
Here I am lecturing to you today.
Thursday.
Somebody's going to be here,
no doubt lecturing to you next week.
Next Tuesday,
the question of survival can be
asked about that very simple case.
Is the person who's going to
be lecturing to you on Tuesday,
the very same person as the person
who is standing in front of you,
lecturing to you.
Now,
will that person survive the weekend?
I certainly expect to survive the weekend,
but what is it to survive the weekend?
What is, well, we might say, look,
we've already got the beginnings of an
answer for me to survive till Tuesday
presumably is for there to be somebody,
some person alive lecturing
to you on Tuesday,
and here's the crucial point for that
person lecture into you on Tuesday,
Debbie,
the very same person as the
person lecturing to you today.
I'm Thursday.
Yeah.
If I were to be killed in a plane accident
this weekend and there was a guest
lecturer for you on Tuesday, there'd
be somebody alive lecturing to you.
But of course that wouldn't be me.
So the question we want to get clear on
is what is it for somebody on Tuesday to
be the same person as the person
here talking to you on Thursday?
And we can ask the question more
grandly about larger expanses of time.
Suppose there's somebody alive.
Yep.
40 odd years from now in the year 2050
could that be me to ask?
Have I survived until 2050 is to ask,
is that person who's alive in 2050 the
very same person as the person who's
standing here now lecturing to you?
Okay.
What is it for somebody in the future?
Tabby.
The very same person as this
person who's here now, today.
Now I'm thinking about this question.
Thinking about this question.
It's important not to miss.
Understand what we're asking.
Some of you may misunderstand
what I'm asking. I mean,
some of you may want to say,
look,
person lecturing to you now has
at least a fair bit of his hair.
He's got a beard.
Let's oppose it.
The Person Alive in 2050
is bald and bent over,
has no beard. How could they be
the same person? One's got heroin,
doesn't one's got a beard, one doesn't.
One stand straight, one's crooked,
cannot be the same person.
That's the mistake that it's
important for us to get clear about.
So I'm going to spend some time talking
about examples that I think we would not
find puzzling and work our way back
up to the case of personal identity.
So first I'm going to say some things
about identity across time or indeed
initially identity across space with
some familiar humdrum material objects.
So let's start.
Suppose you and I are walking
along and we see a train.
So let me draw the train first.
Not
very good artists,
but
all
right,
there's our train.
We start walking.
I point to the locum,
I prompted the caboose.
Let's make this look more like a caboose.
Slightly more that caboose
just so it doesn't look too much like
the locomotive. I pumped in a caboose.
I say, look at that train
and we're walking along,
we're walking along,
we're walking a walking along.
We come to the end of the train and I
pointed a locomotive and they say, wow,
look how long that trade is.
That's the very same train I
pointed to five minutes ago.
We've been walking along it all this time.
Now imagine that you say you wouldn't
say anything as stupid as this,
but imagine that you
said this. You say, yeah,
this isn't the same train as the train
we we pointed to five minutes ago after.
All right, now what you're
pointing to is a locomotive,
whereas five minutes ago what
you pointed to was a caboose.
Caboose isn't the same
thing as a locomotive.
How can you possibly
say it's the same thing?
Who could possibly make
a mistake like that?
You know though the locomotives
got smoke coming out of it,
the caboose doesn't and so forth and so
on. A lot of differences between the two.
How can you make such a silly
mistake? Well, of course.
What I would then want to say to you is,
no,
actually you're the one who's
making the mistake. I agree.
Of course that a locomotive is
not the same thing as a caboose,
but it wasn't claiming that.
It was rather initially
when we started our walk,
I pointed to a caboose,
but by pointing to the caboose,
I picked out a train.
I said,
look at that train.
And what I was referring
to wasn't just the caboose,
but the whole long extended
through space object.
The train which took
the boost is just apart.
Okay.
And when at the end of our walk when
I pointed to a locomotive and said,
look at that train by
pointing to the locomotive,
I was picking out a train and entire
train this long extended through space
object,
the train.
And when I said this train that I'm
pointing to now is the very same train as
the train I pointed to five minutes ago.
I'm not saying what is certainly false.
I'm not saying the locomotive is
the same thing as the caboose.
Rather.
What I'm saying is the entire
extended through space train
that I'm pointing out now is this same
train as the entire extended through
space train that I picked
out five minutes ago.
And that claim far from
being false is true.
Now, as I say, none of us
would make that mistake,
but it's attempting mistake
if you're not being careful.
And that mistake might mislead us if
we start thinking about the personal
identity case. But let's continue
with the train for a bit.
Suppose
as we taking our walk,
part of the train isn't invisible.
There is a large
warehouse that's blocking the view.
Walking along the way, we see a
caboose. I say, Huh, there's a train.
Then for a while we're walking.
We don't see anything because
all you can see is the warehouse
and then after we get past the warehouse,
very long block, long warehouse,
I see a locomotive and I say, Hey, look,
there's a train and then I ask you,
do you think this is the same train
as the train we pointed to before?
Now again, it's important not to
misunderstand that question, right?
That questions not asking
is the locomotive that we're
pointing to now the same
as the caboose that we pointed
to earlier? No, of course not.
The locomotive is not the same as the
caboose, but that's not what I'm asking.
What I'm asking rather is,
remember earlier when I pointed to the
caboose in doing so and I started talking
about a train,
I was picking out some entire
extended through space train.
Right now in pointing to a locomotive,
I'm picking out not just locomotive, I
mean to be talking about an entire train,
some entire extended through space train
and I'm asking not about the locomotive
and the caboose,
but rather I'm asking about the trains.
Did I pick out by means of
the locomotive and caboose,
are they the same train and
the answer is don't know,
can't tell the buildings
blocking the view.
Suppose we had x ray vision
and could see through
the building. Then the answer would
be, well look, if what we've got is
something like this.
Then of course we do
have one single train.
The extended through space train I picked
out at the end of our walk is the same
as the extended through space train that
I picked out at the beginning of our
walk,
but it might not turn out that way.
It might turn out if I had x ray
vision that what I'd see is this,
then the answer would be, oh,
there's not one train here,
but two trains.
The extended through space
train that I'm picking out.
When I pointed a locomotive,
turns out to be a different train from
the extended through space train I picked
out, when I pointed to the caboose,
they don't have ECS revision.
I don't know which of these metaphysical
hypotheses is the correct one.
All right.
Easy enough with trains.
We know how it works with trains.
Okay,
well let's talk about something
not a whole lot more complicated.
Cars
used to have a car I bought in 1990
yes.
My ability to draw cars is even
worse than my ability to draw trains.
There's my car in 1990 it was new.
Okay.
Was sparkly.
Yeah.
Then I drove it for some years and I
got some dense and so forth and so on.
It's a smile
by 1996 or 2000 wasn't looking so good.
Sparkler gone. Had a couple of
dance. That was the car in 2000
by 2006
had a lot of dance.
2006 when it finally died.
All right.
Now we all understand the claim that
the car I had in 2006 was the very same
cars.
The car I had in 1990
of course.
Again
gotta be careful not to
misunderstand what's being said.
We all know that in 2006 the car had a
lot of scratches and had gotten banged in
on one side and
pretty sorry looking in terms of the
scrapes and the paint job and the rust.
Whereas the car in 1990
new and shiny and smooth
might say
that 2006 cars stage is obviously not
the same thing as the 1990 car stage.
That's like thinking that the locomotive
is the same thing as the caboose,
but when I say it's the same car,
I don't mean they be
talking about car stages.
I mean to be talking about a single
thing
that was extended through time.
There I am proud owner of my new
car in 1990 and I say this is a car.
It's a car that will exist
for more than a few minutes.
It's a car that will exist for years
and years and years though at the time I
didn't realize what was going
to last 16 years or longer.
When I refer to my car as opposed to what
we could dub the car stage or the car
slice.
When I refer to the car in 1990 I mean
to be talking about the entire extended
through time object
2006 when I point to that sad heap.
Okay.
And talk about,
I've had that car for 16 years.
Well I haven't had that
car stage for 16 years.
That car stage or that car slice if
we wanted to talk about it that way.
It has only been around
for however long months,
years a year hasn't been around for 16
years, but when I talk about that car,
I'm picking just the current slice
or the current stage of the car,
but the entire extended
through time object.
Okay.
When I say that's the very
same car I've had for 16 years,
I mean,
okay,
think of the object extended through
time that I'm picking out by pointing to
the current slice.
That's the very same extended through
time object that I picked out 16 years ago
by pointing to what was then the current
slice. The slices aren't the same.
The car is the same.
It's the very same car.
Okay,
well now let's imagine a
somewhat more difficult case.
The end of 2006 my engine failed.
I sold the car to a dealer.
Junk dealer.
Suppose that in 2010
I see a car.
Okay
and the junk lot
and it looks familiar to me.
Take, Whoa, that's my car.
Is it or isn't it my car?
This is sort of like the case with
the factory blocking the view.
Yeah.
1990 to 2006 very easy.
Saw the car everyday in my garage,
but here's a four year
set of a factory blocking my view.
It's the mists of time blocking
my view and I ask same car or not.
Again, by this time I imagine you
don't need to be warned. Well,
let me just warn you a couple more times.
I'm not asking,
is the car stage the 2010 car stage,
the same car stage as the 2006 car stage?
Maybe not. Maybe. Obviously not.
I'm asking rather in pointing
to the 2010 car stage.
I mean to be picking out an entire
extended through time entity.
The car and I'm asking is that the very
same extended through time entity as the
extended through time
entity that I used to own.
I wonder and the answer is don't know
the mists of time or blocking my view.
I don't know the answer,
but we know what the possibilities are.
One possibility is that
indeed it's the very same.
All right.
Won't draw it all.
Oh, 2008 and so forth. It
couldn't be the very same car.
If we knew what it took to have the
various stages of a car add up to the very
same car,
then that would be one possibility,
but there might be
a different possibility.
Could have been that after I sold it
to the junk dealer, he crushed it,
turned it into a heap of metal and that
was the end of my car and the car I'm
seeing on the dealer's lot in
2010 it might be some other car
with its own history.
What we're wondering about
is is there a single, oh,
here's a piece of jargon.
Is there a single space time
worm here or are there too?
When I look at the the car in
2010 and say there is a car,
I wonder if it's the same car.
I'm asking about this thing
that's extended obviously
through space since cars
take up some space and through time.
Okay.
Looks a bit like a worms.
So philosophers call them spacetime worms
is the space time worm that makes up this
car the same space time or him as the
one that made up my car,
one worm there or two and the
answer might be don't know,
need to have more facts,
but at least that's what
the question is now,
metaphysically there's different ways of
trying to pose the set of issues that I
had begun to talk about.
Should we say,
as we might say with the train,
the train is made up
out of the various cars,
the locomotive, the caboose,
and the intervening cars.
So the train, that's the, that's the
way we normally think about trains,
at least the way I normally
think about trains,
the trains a bit like a sandwich,
right?
The metaphysically fundamental things
are the caboose, the locomotives,
the intervening trains. If they're
glued together in the right way,
they make up a train. What's
the right kind of metaphysical
glue for trains? Well,
it's being connected
with those little locks
that may or may not be the right way to
think about what I've been calling car
stages or car slices on some metaphysical
views you might say just exactly like
what the train their car stages or the
metaphysically fundamental things and an
a car or something extended through time
is glued together like a sandwich from,
uh,
the car stages.
And then we might worry about what's the
relevant metaphysical glue for cars and
other metaphysical views.
No,
what's really prior is the car itself
and talking about car stages is a certain
convenience,
a kind of way of chopping up
the fundamental thing, the car.
So to use an analogy that
I think David Kaplan,
a philosopher at UCLA offers,
it's as though you have to think of it
more like a Bologna or Salami that you
can slice it for certain purposes.
You can talk about slices,
but the fundamental things to Salami.
Yeah.
All right.
In thinking about cars,
should we say that the fundamental
thing is the car stages and they get put
together like a sandwich to make cars
or should we think that the fundamental
thing is the car extended through time
and they can be sliced up to make cars
stages for our purposes,
I think we won't have to go there.
It doesn't really matter.
As long as we're comfortable talking
about entire spacetime worms,
the cars and the slices are the
stages we don't have to ask,
which is metaphysically prior.
Should also notice that.
I should also mention that there are other
metaphysical views about what goes on
when an object exists over time.
Uh,
I've been here helping myself to the
suggestion that we should think about
extension over time and now all will
this lead to the way we think about
extension over space. That's why I
started with, uh, a spatial example,
the train and move to the 10
poral example, the car. And,
and there are those philosophers who think
that's exactly the right way to think
about it. And those philosophers, I
think, no, no, that's misleading. Uh,
when an object is extended over a time.
Really the entire objects right
there at every single moment.
These are interesting and
difficult questions, but again,
I think for our purposes
we don't have to go there
so I will help myself to
this language of space,
time,
worms,
objects that extend not only over space
but also over time and distinguish the
entire worm from the various slices or
stages that either make up the warm where
that we could slice the warm into.
The point that I've been emphasizing is,
well first point of course has been
don't confuse the stages with the entire
space.
Time worm.
The stages can differ without the entire
space time I'm being a different worm.
Okay.
Second question.
I've hinted at that we're about to turn
two and not literally turned to them
longer but so shortly we'll turn
to is what's the relevant glue?
What makes two stages stages
of the very same thing.
The case of trains, as I
say, it's fairly obvious.
What is it in the case of cars,
what makes
the 1990 car stage a stage
in the very same car?
The extended through space and time,
warm car as the 2006 stage.
What's the metaphysical glue that glues
the stages together and the answer,
not that there aren't puzzled about it,
but the answer's roughly.
It's the very same car if it's the
very same hunk of metal and plastic and
wires.
Yep.
There was the car cars,
just some metal and plastic rubber and
that very same honk continued into 2000
and continued into 2006
okay.
The glue,
the key to identity across time for
cars is being the same hunk of stuff.
Now that doesn't mean it's got
to be the same Adam for Adam,
we know that's not true.
Think about my steering wheel.
Every time I grabbed the
steering wheel to drive,
I wore away thousands of Adams.
You can lose some atoms and still
be this very same steering wheel.
Okay,
that'd be no,
and then I'd replace the tires on my car,
but for all that it was
the same hunk of stuff.
Now, this is ways, it's sort
of an interesting issue.
How money changes of the constituent
parts can you have and still be the same
hunk of stuff.
Okay.
If this was a class in which we were going
to worry about the general problem of
identity across time, this would be
a problem we'd have to directly face.
But since we are only looking at uh,
north of the problem of identity to get
to the question that we really want to
think about the nature of
personal identity across,
I'm not going to pursue that.
I just want to flag the thought that
you can be the very same hunk of stuff.
Even if some of the constituent atoms
have changed along the way and even bigger
parts,
you can replace the,
the headlights and still be the
same hunk of stuff and right.
That's what's going on in the car case.
Same hunk of stuff.
1900 to 2006 and when I seen the car on
the junk dealer's yard in 2010 and ask
is that my car or not?
The answer lies in if only we could know.
So at the same hunk of stuff or not.
That's what the key,
the metaphysical glue is
being the same hunk of stuff.
All right,
turn now to the case,
we really wonder about
personal identity.
Here's somebody
lecturing to you.
Okay.
In 2007
Shelly Kagan,
we imagine there's somebody
in 2050
okay,
and we ask, is that Shelly
Kagan? We'll call him mr x.
We ask is that the same person or not?
Now again,
this point, you're not going to be tempted
by the mistake, right? I'm not asking,
is this person stage Mr x,
this same person's stage as s k 2007
obviously nots k 2007 still got his hair.
Has the beard stands up
more or less straight?
Mr X's ball doesn't have a beard.
I should.
I suppose I should have drawn him bent.
Can I do that little cane right?
I'm not asking is the person's stage Mr
x the same as the person stage sk 2007
how's it go?
Computers get the SK two not asking that.
I'm asking.
I'm saying you look,
when you look at the current stage,
the current person slice and think
about the entire extended through time
entity.
The person that makes up Shelly Kagan,
where that is Shelly Kagan,
is that the very same person
as the extended through
time person that you got in
mind when you point to the Mr x 2050
yeah.
The stages are obviously different but
by looking at the stages we pick out a
space time worm
that makes up a person and we're asking
is that the very same space time where
it as the one we picked up previously
or different spacetime worm than the one
we picked up previously.
And the answer presumably is going to be,
well it depends on getting
clear on whether the stages
are glued together in the
right metaphysical way.
Okay.
And so what we'd like to know is,
well what does it take for two person
stages to make up or be part of the very
same extended through time person.
What's the metaphysical
glue that underlies being a
single extended through time
person?
What's not key to personal identity.
Okay.
If we could get clear about what the
answer to that metaphysical question,
the key to personal identity,
we'd at least know what we needed
to find out to answer the question.
Is this one person or two,
are the pieces glued
together in the right way?
Different question.
The question that were ultimately
hoping to get an answer to.
Yeah.
Could I survive my death? Well, look,
think again about the question we
started with, could I survive the weekend
to survive the weekend?
There's gotta be somebody who's alive,
some person
on Tuesday
and that person's got to be the very same
person as the person you're looking at
mag you're thinking about now.
Or to put it in terms of stages,
that person's gotta be that stage.
That slice has to be part of the very
same extended through time space,
time worm as as this stage is
it gotta be glued
together in the right way.
The can't tell whether that's true
until we know what the glue is,
but at least we anticipate that there
be somebody here on Tuesday who is glued
together in that way the right way,
whatever that turns out to be the stage,
it'll be glued together in the right way.
Suppose I ask then will
I survive my death?
All right,
so I'm going to be optimistic.
I'm going to assume that I make it to 2040
okay.
2040 won't even be nine to yet.
That's not to wildly optimistic.
It's optimistic but not wildly optimistic.
So here's the SK 2040
we know that
there's an extended through space and
time, space, time where I'm a person,
Ben's suppose sadly 2041
my body dies and they ask,
could I survive my death?
That is to say the death of my body.
Well,
we want to know after 2041 let's say
2045 is there somebody who's a person
call him mister X.
Could it be the case that there'd be a
person in 2045 after the death of my body
in 2041 could it be the case that there's
a person who's part of the very sane
spacetime warm,
but you're thinking about right now?
Could that be or not?
We can't answer that question until we
are clear about what does it take to have
identity across time.
What's the key to personal identity?
What's the metaphysical glue?
Once we get clear about what the
relevant metaphysical glue is,
we'll be in a position just started
asking could this happen or not?
All
right.
That's the question I want to turn to.
Then what are the possible
positions on this question?
What's the key to personal identity?
What's it to be that very same person as
we might put it somewhat misleadingly.
What is it for to quote unquote people
to really be the same single extended
through time person.
Suppose we believed in souls.
Then here would be a natural proposal.
That metaphysical key to personal
identity is having the very same soul,
so I suppose I was a
duelist. I'd say, look,
you're looking at a body but connected
in this intimate way with his body is a
particular soul. The
soul obs, Shelly Kagan.
What makes it true that the person
lecturing to you next Tuesday is Shelly
Kagan,
the very same person.
What makes that true is that
it's the very same soul.
As long as this soul is here.
Again,
on Tuesday it'll be Shelly
Kagan if it's a different soul.
It's not Shelly Kagan.
That's the natural thing to suggest.
If we believe in the soul view,
the key to personal identity,
not the only thing of
soul theorists can say,
but the natural thing for a sole theorist
to say the key to personal identity is
having the very same Sol saying Sol,
same person, different
soul, different person.
Imagine that God or a
demon or what have you,
for whatever perverse reason severs the
ordinary connection between my body and
my soul and then reconnects the wires
as it were so that there's a different
soul animating and controlling
this body on Tuesday
for whatever perverse reasons. Maybe it
makes them sort of philosophical point.
That person decides to come in anyway
on Tuesday and lecture to you about
philosophy
according to the view that we're taking,
which we now call the soul view
according to the soul view.
It won't be me lecturing
to you on Tuesday.
Why not?
Because we just stipulated it's not
the same soul to different soul.
The key to personal identity according
to the sole theory of personal identity,
the key to personal identities,
having the same soul.
When I asked myself,
will I survive the weekend?
What I'm asking is no. Well, my soul
is still be around. Come Tuesday.
As long as my soul still exist in
his functioning, it's still me.
I'm still around. In fact,
peeking ahead, of course,
and this is why we often
drawn his soul views.
Even if my body dies,
as long as my soul continues to exist,
I continued to exist.
The key to personal identity according
to the soul views having the same soul.
As long as my soul continues to exist,
it's still me.
Whether or not my body's still alive,
okay.
As precisely for this reason that at
least the salt belief in the soul combined
with the sole theory of personal identity
holds out the possibility of surviving
my death.
We may not know that the soul will
continue to exist after the destruction of
the body, but at least it seems like a
possibility. Plato, of course, as we know,
tried to argue that we could know if
there was or there are good grounds for
believing the soul would
continue to exist. I said,
I don't find those grounds so convincing,
but even if we didn't think we could show
that the soul would continue to exist,
at least it could.
It would make perfect sense to
think about it continuing to exist
and so I could survive
the death of my body.
In contrast,
it looks the prospects don't look so
promising for survive in my death of my
body. If we don't believe in
dualism, if we're physical lists,
if a,
if a person is just a p functioning body,
how could it be that after the death
of his body, he's still around? Well,
we'll say more about that a little
bit later. Come back to the soul view.
It's me. As long as it's
the same soul, it's not me.
If it's a different soul,
now consider the following possibility.
Okay?
Suppose that over the weekend
at 3:00 AM Saturdays Nights,
Sunday morning,
while I'm asleep,
God replaces my soul
with a different soul,
hooks it up to the body,
gives that soul,
that replacement soul.
All of my memories,
all of my beliefs,
all of my desires,
all my intentions.
Somebody wakes up Sunday
morning, says, Hey,
it's great day, wonderful to be alive.
I'm Shelly Kagan, got to get to work.
Whatever it is,
says I'm Shelly Kagan,
but he's not according to the soul view.
He's not because according to the sole
theory of personal identity to be me,
that person's got to have my soul and
in this story he doesn't have my soul.
My soul got destroyed.
Let's suppose 3:00 AM Sunday morning,
a new soul got created.
It's not me.
There's a person there,
all right?
It's a person that doesn't
have a very long history.
Maybe he'll go on to have a long history,
but it's a different extended
through space and time person.
Then the one you're
thinking about right now,
because according to
the soul view to be me,
it's got to have the same soul and
we just stipulated not the same soul.
Think about what that means.
If God were to replace
my soul Saturday night,
I die.
And the thing that wakes
up Sunday isn't me.
Of course he think he was me.
He thinks to himself.
I'm the very same person who was
lecturing about philosophy last week,
but he'd be wrong.
Isn't the same person because it's
not the same soul. He be wrong.
And notice this,
there'd be no way at all.
He could tell,
he can check his beliefs,
he can check his desires,
he can check his memories.
But that's not the key to personal
identity. According to the soul of view,
the key to personal identity
according to soul views,
having the very same
soul can't check that.
You can't see the soul to
see if it's the same one.
So this would have happened to him.
He wouldn't be Shelly Kagan,
the person who'd been lecturing last week,
but there'd be no way at all.
He could know that.
And now the question you
need to ask yourself is,
how do you know this didn't
happen to you last night?
You woke up this morning thinking,
I'm the very same person, Joe, Linda,
Sally,
whatever it is.
The very same person who
was in class yesterday,
how do you know?
How could you possibly know if God
replaced your soul with a new one,
destroyed the old one, gave the new one?
All the old memories, beliefs, desires,
goals, and so forth. That person
who was in class last week,
yesterday died.
The person who's here now hasn't been
around 10 years, 20 years, what have you.
Yeah,
you were born a few hours ago and
there'd be no way at all that you could
possibly tell.
How do you know not only that
it didn't happen to you last?
How do you know something like this
doesn't happen every single night,
every hour on the hour,
every minute,
every second God whips
out the old soul destroys.
It puts in a new one with maybe souls
only last for a minute and a half.
Okay?
If that was happening,
then people don't last very long.
Bodies May last 20 years, 50
years, 80 years, a hundred years,
but people would only last an hour or if
it's every minute substitution a minute
and you'd never possibly be able to tell.
Now these worries were
raised by John Locke,
great British philosopher,
and he thought,
this is too big a pill to swallow.
This is too big a bullet to bite.
We can't take seriously the suggestion
that there was no way at all to tell
whether it was still me from the one day
to the next from one hour to the next,
from one minute to the next.
Just not plausible.
It's not that there's anything in coherent
about this year that does anything
logically contradictory about this view.
You just have to ask yourself,
could this really be,
what personal identities all about that
there'd be no way at all to tell whether
I've survived from one minute to the
next from one hour to the next lock
thought,
no,
you couldn't possibly take this view
seriously if you thought about what it
meant.
Notice this is not an argument
that souls don't exist.
If you find this argument convincing,
what it's an argument for is the
claim that even if souls do exist,
they may not be the key
to personal identity.
And so what we have to ask
ourselves is what's the alternative?
What better suggestion is there for what
we could point to as the metaphysical
glue,
the key to personal identity.
And that's the question
that will take up next time.